[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux pôles de la planète ont connu
en mars dernier des vagues de chaleur
record en antarctique on enregistré une
température de près de 40 degrés celsius
au dessus de la moyenne saisonnière et à
l'article la hausse a été d'une
trentaine de degrés on l'a vu cette
semaine avec le rapport du giec la
planète se réchauffe et l'une des
conséquences en est la fonte accélérée
des glaciers partout à travers le monde
les glaciers disparaissent au c c'était
écrit dans le ciel
les derniers relevés montrent la cadence
à laquelle cela se produit au groenland
une elle aussi vaste que le québec et le
labrador réunit la glace prend le large
où se liquéfier coule vers l'océan
les classiers recul de 6 à 7 fois plus
vite qu'il ya 25 ans
chaque année l'île vers plus de glace
qu'elle n'en accumulent
le satellite green's l'a observé les
chercheurs danois l'on calculé
depuis 2002 le gros add même perd en
moyenne 2 179 gigatonnes de glace par an
surtout du côté ouest vers le canada
c'est près de 5000 gigatonnes de glace
perdue en près de 20 ans
résultat les classes recul vers
l'intérieur des fior et découvre de plus
en plus de relief
le réchauffement de l'air et de l'eau
gruge la glace de parents pas
dans l'archipel arctique canadien juste
à côté le temps se réchauffe aussi de
trois à quatre fois plus vite
qu'ailleurs
la banquise en prend un coup on estime
qu'elle perd en moyenne 13 % de sa
surface tous les dix ans
dans l'ouest canadien les glaciers n'ont
pas meilleure mine
les vagues de chaleur en 2021 ont
maintenu le mercure élevé et les feux de
forêt ont transporté de la suite sur les
glaciers
plus foncé qu'à l'habitude les glaces et
absorbent plus de chaleur ce qui
précipite leur fonte le glacis pitot
dans le parc national de banff a reculé
de 2 100 mètres en un an seulement la
glace et retient dix fois plus vite
qu'au cours des 50 dernières années
[Musique]
à quinze mille kilomètres de là en
antarctique les brèches dans glaciers se
multiplient sous nos yeux
la moyenne de glace annuelle perdu
depuis 2002 est de 149 gigatonnes la
moitié moins qu'au groenland mais dans
une région très concentré à l'ouest
le glacier thwaites s'en trouvera aussi
grand que l'état de la floride est sous
haute surveillance
au fur et à mesure que l'eau maire de
bruges par en dessous il perd son solide
appui sur le fond rocheux en vingt ans
sans point d'appui a reculé de 14 km il
pourrait se fracturer en de gigantesques
blanc emportées par l'eau c'est en
privant ainsi d'autres glaciers plus à
l'intérieur de protection en les
exposant du coup aux assauts de l'océan
[Musique]
les glaciers continentaux qui fonde en
antarctique comme au groenland bien sûr
ces deux longs en plus dans les océans
et plus la frontière de la glace recul
plus la ligue 2 au monde
le niveau des mers s'est élevé de près
de 18 cm durant le siècle dernier
il pourrait grimper encore de 30
centimètres à deux mètres d'ici 2100
cela dépendra de la cadence du
réchauffement
avec ses glacier qui disparaît c'est la
montée des eaux disparaître sans doute
aussi une partie de nos comptabilité et
des monuments compenser tout aussi
immuable que les glaciers